you played with the Jazz okc makes
Portland now Celtics it's a cold
business MBA what is it with you and
LeBron bill you can call them Hitler
that's not like a regular thing to call
somebody I don't care if you're like a
king go princess queen whatever you are
I'm just gonna call come after you and
I'm not gonna be scared do you think the
game is more exciting today with ten
years ago now you breathed on somebody
you get $25,000 fine why is America
playing the safe role with Turkey what
is the biggest concern America has with
Turkey it doesn't matter what your
background is it doesn't matter what
your color is it doesn't matter what
your religion is the most important
thing in life is live your differences
on a table and trying to find what we
have in common
not many country have what this country
no doubt about you know the whole
Armenian Genocide what are your thoughts
is a history of Armenian I'm for the
truth it doesn't matter who it's for or
against I want to know what happened and
it feel wrong I'll just say it hey we
are wrong yeah and I will say publicly
I'm actually thinking about and American
politics on this unbelievable I totally
see it value to hate this run homie look
what I become
[Music]
today I have a special guest with me
Enes Kanter who was in town we told him
can you come by and visit let's sit down
and talk we've been trying to make this
work and finally we were able to make
you work for some of you that don't know
who he is he plays for the Celtics
currently one of the most how do I put
it guys who knows how to get under the
skin of other players and be a fun to
watch if you don't know a fun fact 2011
draft pick I think he was the first
round third pick ahead of Tristan
Thompson ahead of klay Thompson and
today's playing for the Celtics and it's
brother thank you for coming out man
crucial for making the time so uh
Celtics one of the first questions I had
for you man I mean I'm a I'm a both the
Campbell fan and I'm also a fan of
Lillard I think both of them are leaders
yes what's the biggest difference
between these two guys oh I mean I would
just say this the both guys you know
what makes him so special is you know
they make themself better and they make
everybody else better run I feel like
that's one they make him really special
I was just like it just really blessed
him to play and future Hall of Famers
like Damian Lillard and get Kemba Walker
I mean before I met Campbell I mean
obviously it wasn't my draft class and I
know he was like it was like a nightmare
to guard but I didn't know he was like
this down-to-earth humble guy good
leader and I always you know he always
laughing always smiling always bringing
a positive energy a good locker room guy
so I'm like wow you know that's very
special
Kimbo is Walker yeah my oh yeah which
one is the style more hey guys that's
come together you can do better and as
you can do beg as let's pull this is it
that or is it also a little bit of
challenging hey what can I do to help
you working on your free throw what can
I do to help you it's in like a
challenging type of leaders it's just a
locker room guy bringing them together
what's the difference between the two I
mean the table's very similar players
very very similar for players you know
they're both trying to help I mean they
they challenged me to be I mean
obviously they know I'm a you know
really good offensive player where they
both work to challenge me to be a really
good defensively they all they're both
to like hey we know you can score the
ball we can rebound the ball boy we to
get to your next level we need to be
good on defensively so that's why they
both the challenge but very very similar
players it's a similar play very similar
place
and again they're both incredible to
watch and any time you're playing you're
entertaining to watch me you're gonna do
your fight but at the same I got that
you know that you cut your eyes you're
like you guys you're going after me
doesn't matter they're trying to clean
the blood off your nose you watch that
yeah so what is it with you in the Brawn
bill man I mean you know you it's like
when when you and LeBron are on you're
like some way I don't know why you do it
what is it with the two person I mean
obviously I respect he's obviously one
of the best best player to ever play
this game you know but I'm obviously
it's like I will do anything to win that
game obviously in the court you just got
to go out there and fight but off the
court I mean obviously like each other
as get them get on the skin and it's
it's tough it's mentally so strong but I
you know like I do everything I fight I
trashed all I do
I push him I try to fight with him but
it just he just keep focused and
focusing on want honesty money it's
always a good challenge because like
what I found with the career okay I'm
gonna be like hey man I got a you know I
got a I got AI got a fight with LeBron
or I got played against them or I won't
or you you we lost whatever so it's
definitely a blessing to have a guy like
represent and be like that is do you go
after them because to you it's kind of
like no one intimidates you because of
where you I'm from Iran you from Turin
okay you have a lot of turmoil so not a
lot scares you and you kind of want to
go after they can't get that far because
everybody's afraid of them like yeah I'm
scared of a dictator so I've been called
a miser I don't care if you're like a
king or princess queen whatever you are
I'm just gonna call come off there you
and I'm not gonna be scared so if you're
not afraid of a dictator you're not
gonna be afraid we can't there you go
you got it so a question for you the
part about LeBron that that's most
impressive the way he's been handling a
lot of stuff ladies it's incredible I
don't want to see how this guy's
handling stuff with brawny with his team
right a leadership with the way he's
having certain issues with the NBA he's
developed into a whole other person the
part that's very impressive this is a
big guy he goes through me he's been hit
hard he gets fouled hard you know cuz
he's got muscles so lot of generated
he's probably hit him and hard
then we even see it officially and move
Shaq lost and he would if somebody
bullied him his first season I watched
Shaq play one time he played a Pistons
and he went in and Alban Robertson was a
guy at that time was pulling him down
uh-huh
and Albert Robertson kind of goes up to
him and he pushes Shaq and Shaq just
punched him in the face
this was the first season like 10 20
games into the season so then you see
Kobe comes in and Kobe gone to fight
would Miller you know Anthony with the
other guy from the Knicks what was his
name uh all these guys that he got into
fights with right you got bird got into
fights all of these guys like yeah hey
LeBron never got into a fistfight with
anybody in the league I don't understand
yeah well I think that the one thing NBA
change in luck a lot of rules you know
like before Dan you're getting a
fistfight you only get him like I
ejected in that game and that's it but
now you you breathe on somebody you get
$25,000 fine and nobody wants that you
push somebody to LeBron I mean no I just
they just don't want to they just don't
want that you know of course LeBron of
them people loves them and they just
don't want to have that oppression or
just for fighting against LeBron just
they just don't want that I think I also
don't think it's his personality I think
he's yeah I think he's I think he's a
locker room guy when I see him I see him
as a guy that glues that brings
everybody yes see to see Dwight Howard
play the way he's playing right I have
not seen Dwight Howard this happy I
don't know if I've ever seen Dwight as
happy and I think a lot of that has to
do with LeBrons nothing so leadership a
question for you for the game today do
you think the game is more exciting
today or 10 years ago 20 years ago
regular season not playoffs yeah I'm
trying to think well I think right now
and B is just I mean you like I said in
your brief on the guy they could they
call a foul yeah a bad I feel like back
then it was just more physical and you
see that there was like more back to the
basket players in row but now it's all
about shooting threes no contact just
pick and pop shoot threes truth is I
feel like back in the day was I feel
like it was more excited more exciting
but I think so I think so I have a
friend of mine who's in New York he's in
Jersey zimmy's Gerard okay I said you
know what do you think about the NBA
right now and he says you know I don't
the season is that exciting today so
tell me why is because everybody's
shooting threes 43035 he says I think
it'd be more exciting if they made the
three like they took her back I don't
know four feet five feet and said they
added four pointer and then half court
and then he said if they took a dunk to
three points instead of two points he
said if they made a dunk three points
instead of two points okay then
they're gonna make the rest a guy the
game would change to be a big guy
because now if you got a Shack just send
dunks in a game that's thirty four so
she would increase the level of wanting
to play that's against the three what do
you think about that I love it because
my game has always been like you know
you know but just back to basket going
signed rebounds put backs and post-op
footers well yeah I do - I do but now
everybody's like yeah you gotta be able
to shoot the three by you know like if
I'm sure the times gotta get offensive
rebounds you know I mean so it's like
about what he said is very interesting I
love it he made the dunk three points oh
my god oh yeah over you actually want to
them Atlanta Hawks facility we practice
there as a team last year and I think
they have a four-pointer just because of
Trey young so they pulled like in a
practice that they put a fourth put off
oh yeah ask Mike what is this like this
for planner for Trey and I'm like wow
this is interesting it would change the
game I think I did when he said that to
me I said you know what I think it's a
creative idea I don't know they would do
it but they seemed silver seems a little
bit creative huh that he may do it but
who knows maybe maybe he will maybe you
want being in the NBA you played with
the Jazz you played with OKC Knicks
Portland now Celtics how do you handle
the fact that the league is a trade
league were you going how do you handle
that aspect because for me when we have
conversations I always say if I mean if
I'm a NBA player Major League Baseball
player or you know just somebody that's
playing professional sports if I'm in
Hollywood if I'm a singer marriage and
doing that while I'm playing I don't
know about that stuff and in sports
you're moving oh my god yes well I mean
one thing I learned to never buy a house
because you get a you never buy a house
you get a trade it is like it's it's so
tough because that
like I'm single you know I don't have it
out it's only me but like I see like my
players teammates have like you know
they have kids going to school they have
wives having a job and that this guy's
getting traded so you have to move
everybody you have to get the kids out
of the school that they don't want that
you have to you know they take the you
know if but if they want to stay in that
city they can but it just tougher to how
transition but it just it just a cold
businessman it's a cold business MBA but
I just gotta stick with it and I see
someone who I see this guy had eight
different teams in nine years I'm like
this is wild his name what this you know
like you know like no but you know like
I said something like that something he
is like a three-four he plays mean he's
not evil yeah
it's a part about the game you look at
it on but when I look at you man you
have a smile on your face all the time
yeah you're being interviewed it doesn't
matter what you're talking about right
at the obviously at the end of the e60
documentary when they did on very
serious we've got a light-hearted side
of you that probably helps you handle
issues like this that comes yeah for
sure I feel like if you lose smile you
lose hope so you always have to be
smiles every positive you cannot show
your enemies any weaknesses you know
you're so yours after me I mean I feel
like and I feel like God blessed me with
so much you don't want it off the court
you know and I cannot be just be down or
my teammates or any of my friends
outside of basketball so I always have
to smell my smell on my face and just go
out there and just imitating people do
you feel like you are the luckiest man
alive to live in America and play math
do you feel that way yourself oh yeah
for sure man especially especially being
the situation being America because I
mean not many country have what this
country know that about you know freedom
in here if they basketball your respect
you and your money so it just is it's a
good situation of being missile I always
try to tell my teammates or whatever I
go to a school or a basketball camp to
talk to the kids I'm like you guys are
blessed to be in this situation
don't take it for granted I agree and
but you know transition with that into
some of the political side because when
I read your story and I hear your story
I relate to it I lived
around ten years and when how many died
Iran was a mess and I was born October
1878 three months before the Shah was an
exile so there's a lot of similarities
with what's going on with the history
there so how many died six weeks later
we escaped we go to Germany we seek
asylum okay and then from Germany we
wait for our green card then I get the
green card I come out here and then I
wanted to become a u.s. citizen so I
joined the army and in June of 99 I got
out of the army two months early to go
swear in anyway June 21st I became a US
citizen so I remember the feeling of
what it was like to become a citizen
especially for you now the other part
that we have in common is is you're very
vocal I'm pretty vocal as well you know
some of the things that I talk about
where my investors sometimes say I don't
know if you want to talk about that you
know you you shouldn't be talking about
this you shouldn't talk about this how
is it you're so comfortable talking
about topics that most people are
uncomfortable with well because I know
this matters more than basketball this
matters more than my this is beginning
my my career basketball and being
everything I'm doing because why I mean
I am blessed because God gave me this
platform and I'm using I'm trying to use
this platform to be voice of all those
innocent people who don't have one back
in turn to Turkey and so I'm like I
can't I remember man just I get this
question a lot am I crazy like this this
three worlds is Tucker comes to my mind
all the time my teammates coaches the
fans everybody asking this question
because they're like you want to be a
player just keep your mouth shut
make your millions just be happy and
live a happy life like what are you
doing with all this like dramas and all
those threads and all that but they
don't understand this conversations like
I said against way way bigger than
everything I'm doing I understand my
family still back in Turkey but my
family's just one there are a thousand
families out there and they're suffering
so I cannot just be worried about my
family or my career or my endorsement
deals whatever and not talk about these
issues how do you in your own mind
process that you know when you come out
and you call the
you know the the president the Prime
Minister their Hitler you're doing this
one you were Romania I think you weren't
Romania at the airport when you were
stuck there because they revoked the
pony dony shell your friend told you got
to leave Indonesia then you go to
Romania each other you go to Singapore
and from Singapore to Romania then
you're stuck that you do the live then
you go to London and then you finally
make it to us 48 hours later and you did
that live and you call them Hitler yeah
you know I mean that's not like a
regular thing to call somebody so I mean
if you look at what's happened in Turkey
first of all in Indonesia the reason I
left it's all started because they try
to kidnap me in Indonesia wait
so the Turkish government working with
the some of some other countries like
Indonesia Malaysia Bosnia to to you know
the kidnapped people there as Senator
Turkey so while I had a basketball
clinic in school in Indonesia and you
know they sent army and intelligence
service to come and talk to me that's
that's what they said so luckily we got
a little bit we learn about that early
and we left it left the country and I
went to Romania they broke my passport
and everything but uh you know people
know my story because I play an MBA
right but there are thousand stores out
there is way worse than mine because you
guys know my story because I have I have
this future a platform but um you know
if you look at what's happening in
Turkey specially after all I'll say
faith quits and you know it was that big
one a fake coup attempt so yes equip
them the turkey is the number one
country in the world uh Pro moisture on
us in in jail over 300 and there are
17,000 innocent woman are in a jail
right now and almost 1,000 babies in the
jail with their mother growing up in
jails you know there's lots of reports
Amnesty International Human Rights for a
foundation are saying that their people
are getting kidnapped people are getting
torturers in jail people are getting
ready raped in jail so I'm like I'm
trying to tell this world that like I
said again I like you guys know my story
but this is what's happy no there yeah
and why is so why are they having such a
challenge in telling when I look at
politically right now you hear what
they're saying but Obama in 2006 right
after the coup that happen
I think July 15 to 20 16 July 16 2015
2016 and then the next day mr. Gulen God
and told the fact that you know we
didn't know this what's happening but
when he when he said that when the coup
took place 249 yeah people notice people
died all these things is Barack Obama
defended when he talked to her to God
saying that nothing was really happening
and then Trump is also trying to make
the rest so it's not a democratic thing
or Republican it why is America playing
the safe role with Turkey what is the
biggest concern America has with Turkey
so let me tell you this not many people
know noises but when I when the COO
heroism happened that night I was with
mr. Gulen mhm and
I saw what mr. Gulen day with my own
eyes his sit on his chair and pray for
his country he did not look like he was
orchestrate a coup attempts because he
was just sitting on his chair and then
people I mean I told us to some other
people but he cried that night because
over 200 and that people died so I mean
if you if you want understand who did
the courts I'm you have to look at the
benefits of courts and like I said again
it has been not so you know mediator
shut down and after that quotes and I
don't he wanted to be the one-man show
so I don't understand what America
trauma Obama what I was trying to do but
I know what I know I saw I saw with my
own eyes what this moment what mr.
Gilliam was doing it yeah but what I'm
asking you is if if your movement is
where it's at why isn't is there any
involvement with us to won a defend mr.
Gulen because in January earlier this
year they were talking about possibly
extraditing mr. Gulen olive oil I think
he's staying somewhere in the
Pennsylvania right and to extradite him
back over there because of negotiations
would Aragon and everything that's
taking place here what why is why are so
many people concerned about mr. Gulen
because I see both sides okay because
for me when I lived in you know what I'm
trying to figure out is the following so
I got three characters for myself you
have the show
okay you have a home a knee okay and
then you have a bit of possibly a Saddam
Hussein or Masada okay this is kind of I
see it right Saddam possibly compared to
a err the gun okay let's just say those
two were thing right okay let's say the
Shah Reza pal Mohammad Reza Pahlavi who
made Iran Americanized he brought
education okay more power to women
freedom all this other stuff let's let's
put him to altitude right am I saying
his life which is he's a very well all
right yep very secular yeah he kind of
made a little bit more open freedom you
know people liked when he was there and
relationships got better because you
know our kids like the bridge between
Asia and yogurt and then who is mr.
gülen's because mr. Gulen when you
really dig deep and look at him he's a
brilliant guy in the 60s he started as a
movement and his messaging was different
very westernized hey you know go out
there and make your money
let's go become successful let's go
build businesses and he doesn't take the
mosque route he takes the educational
value should idea when you're with him
what vision is he casting to you so like
like you said it is all about educating
people because instead of going out
there and building mosques he believed
that we need to go out there and build a
more schools we need to educate people
more especially young generation because
he believes we have lots of issues going
on in our century because of uneducated
people and he's his thinking was if we
go out there not just in Turkey now this
moment school school this moment have
schools over 117 country in the world
and this school for not just for Muslims
you can be you know Jewish you can be
Catholic and believing that you don't
believe in God you can be Christian you
can go to the schools and learn about
math and science so when I was with him
you know of course I asked him questions
and stuff and he gave me his stuff well
I asked me and he told me it doesn't
matter where you're from
it doesn't matter what your background
is it doesn't matter what your color is
it doesn't matter what your religion is
the most important thing in life is
leave your differences on a table and
trying to find
have in common and he said this will is
what we have you don't have another
planet to go or live so let's make this
world better together so so that's what
my thing was so every time I go out
there so like my thing was how can we
educate people how can we educate young
generation so they can they can make
their own decision and that decision
will be right
what's his vision though what's he
trying to accomplish because you know
you see his educational schools
it's obviously are they gonna shut down
all this all this yeah 43 whoever that
was a link to him whether it was the
newspaper you know the main media
outlets the shuttles everything they
took him to prison a lot of military a
lot of doctors a lot of educators a lot
of nurses a lot of them but when they
when they went and looked at the I think
60 minutes in 2012 or 2013 when and
investigated to him schooling yeah the
numbers were great okay the level of
education was great extremely creative
the kids were happy the things that
we're creating was impressive and in
America I don't know exactly how many
campuses in how many states but at that
time it was 127 in 30 states it's some
number like that but why are people
worried about him I guess my biggest
thing is what is really his vision
what's he trying to accomplish what he's
trying to accomplish is like I said
again just educate people and create a
younger generation who can make their
own choices and they're gonna be a
stepping stone to something right what
is the vision long-term the vision
that's the vision just how can we
educate our young generation so they can
have a better future they can make the
right decisions and just have a and
respect each other
and and those those people every time I
I see a people who's who's in this
moment is open to dialogue you know
they're how can we respect other
religions of young respect other
cultures are known from each other you
know are you familiar with Scientology
the Church of Scientology no I never
heard that you film it behind the
religion of behind I heard about that a
little bit yeah so Baha'i is a
denomination of Muslim it's kind of like
Mormonism or Jehovah if you had a friend
yeah yeah my year sister Mary - bye
felt very nice people good people but in
the Muslim community when the ship
window how many went to Iran he didn't
like Baha'i anybody that was behind it
was the same situation as Erdogan very
similar situation so I when I look at
the you know mr. Gulen what he's doing I
see an element of bhai and I see an
element of Scientology where you when in
2002 I was curious about religion I was
an atheist twenty five percent twenty
five years of my life my family grew up
Christian dime and Iran people are
getting bombed I don't believe in God I
just don't believe it's possible so I
went in visited Scientology churches all
the time I would go here and they would
say you can be Christian to give me part
of this you know you can be Catholic you
can be part of this this is not about
your religion this is about us having a
common understanding it's a system it
says that would you say it's a similar
model like that where it's not
necessarily you know because you guys
don't pray you're allowed to drink you
can't pray but it's not something that's
big on prayer right it's it's a little
bit more flexible than a typical
religion you would think would you would
you I wouldn't say I don't say it's
flexible I mean no no the mystery
browsers himself is a very religious guy
he prays five times a day he doesn't he
does not drink in need or his followers
don't drink they fall over five times
there but they are thinking we can you
know there is this thing people always
say you cannot mix religion with science
he wants to mix really science with
religion and understanding you know just
because like I said again he believes in
math and science and instead of going
out there and build a mosque you see
he's thinking like hey people already in
the mosque and praying that let's bless
educate people yeah yeah you see from my
standpoint when I lived in Iran my
mother side wanted Khomeini to come and
how many had a lot of similarities to
mr. Gulen a lot because he was a prophet
it was him Imam he was like seen as a
con man loving man caring man so a lot
of rear awnings were like yes you look
at the Shah
you know all he has is all this oil
money we should bring Khomeini here then
how many comes things change very
quickly you know when you see some of
his interviews from years ago he's a
pretty he would be a visionary guy he
said he sounds like a pretty strategic
you know he doesn't seem like a
lightweight guy that's just there seems
to
be a vision behind it you can't build
this kind of an empire without a vision
at the end of it out like I said again
and I think just people like say
especially like the who this moon was
followers all they K all they care about
our future all they care about how can
we build our future better together his
vision his following his followers how
can we build our future better together
how can we build our future together and
who were we going because I'll read this
to you so I just kind of read what I'm
what I saw here's one thing I he says
mr. Gulen said this like you know you
must move within the arteries of the
system without anyone noticing your
existence until you reach all the power
centers you must wait until a time where
you have all the state power and you
have brought to your side all the power
of constitutional institutions in Turkey
right now I get his point fully get it
meaning okay that sounds like somebody
that's a true believer he doesn't sound
like somebody that is not a true
believer in his cause but that also
sounds like a man with a vision like
he's not happy about the way Aragon is
running it obviously had a big falling
out together hey I'm for sure he's not
happy with how everyone run in the
country yeah I mean after if you look at
it right now I mean the people are not
happy economy is going down and then
there's Ben myself you know I don't know
if you heard a lot of Paris attacks oh
yeah I mean of course you know what what
I'm what Turkey's going right now it's a
big mess and of course he doesn't want
his country to go through that kind of
stuff my circular so that's why I'm
saying that's what he's saying if we
build our future if you build our young
generation we can't have a better future
I'm kind of a better country in the
future I get that's why satinwood Rose a
pal of his son okay that we sat down
together in Washington DC had a meeting
with him and with Ted Cruz
so I went to sat down with him when we
talked about Iran okay a possibility of
our separate meetings possibility of
what can happen for Iran to be free
look you told me you love your country
about the government I love Iran
obviously not the government okay I have
I'd love to take my family in Iran show
- yeah sure I love you yeah I'm sure
you're missing your family at the end of
the day if you cut me right here it's
four things I believe I believe the
Syrians my dad
minion is my mom good Iran is where I
was born I believe America because this
place gave me an opportunity I can't
help myself
those four things matter to me a lot
it's very obvious you love Turkey oh
yeah for sure there's no question about
that when I talk about this issues
people thinking like man I don't like my
country know that people are wrong I
love my country this from that I love
money fly that's why I'm trying to fight
for my car I get that you know I fully
believe that but is is your ideal vision
here's a question like an ideal vision
what an ideal vision would be for there
to be a coup to be a fall because in
Iran there has to be one there trying
right now in Iran Lee you saw three
weeks ago I don't know if you followed
it on three weeks ago four hundred
people were killed in Iran Wow like the
younger generation tried to do a
revolution happened on Iran I got
messages all this stuff that comes
because little VPN that can message you
to be able to have access to you but the
part with you is do you think an ideal
situation for Turkey would be if there
is a coup and then mr. Gulen goes back
and helps run the country you think that
would be an ideal situation mr. Leon
don't wanna run the country
100 percent hundred percent he has
nothing he doesn't want to get into
politics and he said there there is
nothing nothing would nothing will good
comment quota because I mean also
innocent people are dying so he doesn't
want he wasn't behind the coup he was
not 100 percent no because I was with
that guy all night so he had no idea I
really know you I yep because I remember
going to to you know I was with him and
he one of his students when I was
followers we brought the news to him and
he was shocked and he couldn't he
couldn't believe it and then he followed
the news and then when he learned that
over 200 people that he saw crying so he
had no idea that it was gonna be a coup
attempt and he does now what I mean he's
that he's an 80 year old sick man and he
does not want to get in the country and
around the country he just want peace
freedom and democracy in the country
that's all he wants why did him in here
- gonna have a falling out I mean what
do you mean the memory when they were
initially they were allies though I want
to call him an ally there was only two
times they were seen together only two
times they were seen together one
in a football match saw a soccer match
and one home is one of the meetings and
I was watching one of his interviews
there the reporter asking the same
question and he said we were never
allies so I don't believe they were ever
allies who said they were never got
himself got it
how bad can the conditions get if
America leaves Turkey the way it is with
the way orders I was running how bad
could it be
very bad I mean because like right now I
mean America's power to put sanctions on
Turkey and maybe hoping to change some
kind of stuff you know something and but
if not you know I feel like Iran will
even the Schroeder country more how do
you think Trump's ham prisoner Trump's
handling it right now I mean I'm sure
you read the letter yeah for sure you
see the letter he wrote as I did would
you think about the letter when you as I
mean Maury can you grab a copy I put on
my desk over there would you would you
think about it first could see the way
comes around pretty that was few of them
so what are you talking about the wall
or nine 101 the Trump was insulting
everyone don't be a fool stop being like
a tough guy
etc no no I I believe that I'm because
he was he is trying to act like he's
trying to act like a tough guy he is
trying to everyone because like I mean
to when he comes to America he wants to
be like a good person wants to be a good
people to hold Americans but when he
when he goes back to his country talk
badly about America and there's been
lots of I don't have it with me right
now but I can show you I see many of
them that it talks badly about not just
America a lot a lot of country a lot of
countries you know that's what it was
with us in Iran we live in Iran you
would see mad bad Omri call death upon
America and non-stop comes up to
negotiation exactly and then there's
there's I remember like watching there's
been like that people are burning
American flags that is wrong it's like
you don't come here and play at one game
and you go go go back to your content to
be another minutes it's like it's just
not cool so you like the way he's going
right now President Trump you would like
him to in your ideal situation put more
sanctions go through that because you
know sanctions are gonna hurt the
economy like it's gonna put them in
shape for sure I know the one isn't
I know that but I think till she like
Tilly gates till we get a freedom and
democracy I think America have enough
power to just change everything and if
you put sanctions on him his family and
his his wealth then I think it's gonna
shake the whole a drowns Richie a minute
if he does it how do you worry about
your dad like maybe if they it's like
what if they retaliate to you and they
go that route is it's still the fact
that the vision is that important that
you have to go look at the bigger
picture of what could happen to Turkey
long term the bigger picture we want is
freedom and democracy so that's why I
mean if like we don't want of course I
mean I don't want anything to happen to
my country but if you don't if people
are not happy if all it is like there's
been not so people are dying and there's
a lot of terrorist attacks and turkeys a
moment you know happen with some some of
the terrorist groups then you know what
I mean just I got I think we got to put
some sections or a to change a game I
think so final thoughts Armenian
Genocide when the Armenian Genocide was
announced I know you and yeah Ilhan you
guys had a bit of a falling out when she
said what she said and she voted I think
present your thoughts of your from
Turkey okay my mother's Armenian that's
a Syrian you know the ole Armenian
Genocide what are your thoughts is a
history of Armenian oh let me let me
tell you this I mean I think ill Hanuman
was the only person who did not sign
them and genocide I mean that's it's
just it just said I'll just say that and
I think if you feel about asking about I
mean genocide I am NOT expert on that
but I heard from the many people that it
did happen it together so you were from
a lot of people that it did I mean I
heard a lot so for friends that I mean
it's usually I have actually my one of
my best friends from Armenia and my one
my best friend for my you know we look
like my father my assistant coach was
our Armenia so a lot I'm like whenever I
talk to him I'm like I got you I get you
guys I know how you guys feeling so for
whenever I see him I try to sit down at
the top command you know just I'm always
asking but can you explain me the
question please
I thought you can explain me the
situation please so I can have a better
understand
what's going on because I'm not that
type of guy I'm not a close-minded guy
I'm open-minded guy I want to know what
happened and if you're wrong I'll just
say it hey we are wrong yeah and I will
say it publicly because I don't care
about I'm for the truth it doesn't
matter who it's for or against so if
it's against the turkey I'll say it hey
it happened but um before I said I
really really need to work on it and
research on it I need two more
especially after what you know Trump
said I don't know if you've read that
what Trump said about I mean in genocide
it was just on the news today he came
out the Senate bill being passed no yeah
actually Trump just said today that
Armenian Genocide did not happen Trump
said it today Trump I think Trump said
it today it was our most genocide didn't
have not happened we can go or we can go
on our that is we can go - on our
Twitter right now and it was actually
trending and if you put on we can look
at it right now
Trump refuses to back recognition of
Armenian Genocide after aired agon story
thank you so I think I think Aragon is
using that as a pure negotiation to say
if you recognize it I'm not doing
nothing with you wow it's gotten up to
that so if Congress said yes yes now
that said yes yeah wow that's pretty
ugly if we got to that situation bother
so I mean unbelievable so I feel sorry
for people who is I mean of course
they're probably feeling we're very sad
and very hurt but you know it's just if
you want to win so many presidents have
had a chance to win the art Obama Bush
Clinton they're prompt everybody's had
the chance to win it they haven't done
it long term plans with you any plans
have you doing politics one day you're
young right I actually a lot of people
asking me - because I remember so
whenever I get to the Boston Celtics
they were watching NBA TV are watching
ESPN I'm like change that channel let's
watch CNN last for let's watch Fox
that's what you're missing your is
freeze so like so we'll keep watching
that and they're asking hey do you ever
like thinking about becoming one one day
I asked him why not
I'm actually thinking about getting
American politics one day I totally see
it I decide thing is I'm not American
born
but I'm you president but once you
become a citizen you can oh yeah go to
other yeah yeah for sure so I am
thinking about it yes
so what he do is to air the gun you
gonna be come to us have a love it that
would be interesting a lot of brother
appreciate you for coming appreciate a
short time we had together but I really
enjoyed you I know I really appreciate
ank you take your body so different kind
of a conversation little bit of MB a
little bit of politics a little bit of
Turkey Armenian Genocide of different
things but if you enjoyed this topic I
got two other guests I want you to watch
one is a sit down I had with Coach
Calipari in front of a few thousand
people we talked about a lot of things
with this career recruiting great
storyteller and the other one is with
the one and only Kobe Bryant which this
interview led to a lot of dialogue in
the NBA and the sports world and again
if you haven't subscribed to our channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]